solve each problem by forming and
solving a suitable quadratic equation
and I'm going to show you three problems
today of which this is the first and
each of them have this same idea that
we're going to be forming our own
equation whatever my base so you know
I'm not gonna hand you it equation
you've got to kind of make it yourself
and then solving it will help us work
out the answers okay so by now hopefully
you've had the opportunity to sort of
scroll down good morning just in time
scroll down the diagram it doesn't have
to be beautiful
that's better
they do provide units there we go
okay so let's kick this off now I think
being that this is a shape with which we
are eminently familiar you might be able
to help me out by suggesting what a
first line might be that might get us
from geometry yes I do have a right
angle from geometry to an equation then
I can work with strengths suggestion x
squared equals two is that the
suggestion oh okay hold on this X x
squared and there's an X minus seven I'm
going to start writing x squared there's
an X minus seven comes on finish off
what strains thought is why is why is he
squaring where did that come from that's
not squared
why is he squaring pythagoras right so
world of square the two shorter side so
i should finish that off right what do i
do with those two squares i had them in
the sum of the squares on the two
shorter sides is equal to the square of
the longer side okay happy time so this
is the first thing i do i translated
from this geometry into this equation
but now that I know what this equation
is I can somewhat temporarily forget
about the fact that has to do geometry
because now my quadratic brain kicks in
okay on my algebra rate so help me out
what am I going to do
suggestions on this first line
so you'd like to subtract this guy from
both sides yeah let's do it okay so I've
got x squared plus X minus 7 squared
minus X plus 2c all squared you guys
happy with that yep straight
take this guy over to this side subtract
for both sides so where do you get x
equals 2 from where where are you seeing
it equals 2x X make X the subject is I
think the phrase you're looking for so
you'd like the like you want your
suggestion was to move this guy subtract
him from both sides right so that you've
got x squared equals data it up right
okay now I want to think about this
suggestion for a minute I'm going to
write it in another color and then I
want to start unpack why this might be
useful and why it might not be so here's
one part that we could take and here's
another path x squared you're suggesting
a subtract from both sides so I'm going
to get this guy okay now you're just
looking yeah okay now we could totally
do this we've seen before though
especially with algebra problems but
really the 80 probably you can do in
mathematics there are lots of ways to
like there are so many parts to your
question there isn't just one recipe for
how to bake a cake now Zacky suggested
this way
Sarang suggested this way now why is
this like your instinct is to get X by
itself over here and then equal started
it up can anyone suggest to me why
strengths instinct is right but it just
so happens that the particular action he
has taken doesn't end up getting us
toward the goal that he's after what's
the problem by subtracting that X minus
7 all squared Y doesn't actually get me
any closer
so what's wrong once which I which I
want to yeah you don't really
aha so you said two things there which
are kind of convince you I don't have a
number over here I still have X terms no
time right so we want all the X's on one
side so that you have x equals blah blah
blah but by subtracting this object here
you've moved some of the X's over to the
other side and so you kind of like I
still have X's everywhere so it's still
kind of a mess right but the instinct is
correct we just have to sort of take a
bit of a longer path to get there which
as wise a key suggestion here which is
ever so slightly different he's just
focus not a different object this gets
all of my X's all on one side and then
I've just got a number over here so are
we okay to contain
pursuing this yeah swagger you okay
you see why we're gonna go this yeah
okay all right so now what I've got all
the X's on one side but can you someone
up so hard you thought can someone else
give me a suggestion of where I could go
forward hmm let me ask you this remember
we were talking about the other day we
were talking about simplifying right and
how simplifying is kind of a weird word
because it can mean different things in
different contexts you've got to sort of
pay attention to what's going on around
to decide whether for example sometimes
factorizing is the best way to go when
we were adding fractures together and we
were had to microwave with the donators
factorizing was the way to go other
times expanding is the way to go okay
now i'm factorized at the moment is this
the simplest way I can write this or is
expanding it simpler expanding civil but
but why why is Experian suryun okay your
suggestion is I should expand right
let's start doing this and then I'm
going to put this question to all of you
as we expand let's see here
x squared minus 14x plus 49
okay I'm gonna continue going my
question is why does this help us
simplify further I think you all know by
the time I get to the end of this line
you're gonna tell me what to do next and
I can only do it because I've expanded
what do I get here
thank you by the way I didn't put
brackets here I could have but I made a
point you might notice to put brackets
here why do you think I did that yeah
yeah so this is my decide hanging out
here right which I know is a really easy
thing to forget can you see why this if
I wrote it without brackets yeah you see
why this is wrong right because that -
applies to everything in here
so it needs to apply to everything here
like so does that make sense okay now
what's the thing
good boys name and what's the thing I'm
gonna do next this is a way I can
simplify but I couldn't do it in
factorized form what can I do - this
starts with a c' something we do two
algebra all the time when it's like
heaps and heaps of stuff we're gonna
collapse it down something we're gonna
collect like terms okay which kind of I
mean canceling is like a fractions thing
but it's gonna end up looking similar
isn't it so I've got next square here in
fact and you you'll notice me I've been
doing this a lot so hopefully without me
telling you so you'll notice how useful
it is I'm getting that more colors right
because there's just so much stuff here
I want to be able to sort of sift out
what's most important what's related to
each other so I'm going to circle in a
particular color if you've got another
one I encourage you to get it out all of
my x squared terms here's one here's one
and here's another one okay now these
are all of the like terms for x squared
you can see I've got a positive one here
positive one here and then I'm
subtracting one yeah so how many X
square toes will I be left with at the
end so you carefully these are these are
the objects on adding and subtracting no
multiplication right just the one right
so I start off with one I add one which
gives me two then I subtract one which
brings me back to one okay so I've got a
single X square no multiplication
happening so multiplication would have
given me an X to the four but I'm adding
and subtracting okay all right those are
the x squared terms what am I gonna look
at next yeah I've got these um these X
terms in here so just watch out there's
this minus sign hanging out there
attached to that so I've got minus 14x
- Forex so I end up with minus 18x and
then what I have left last is this
constant turn right there it is 49 and
minus 4 49 minus 4 that's 45 right ok
great now so this is this is again you
see how so many problems the whole like
a lot of our effort is to take a problem
looks weird and confusing and to
translate it into a problem that
oh I'm familiar with these I know how to
handle these right